[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
23 anni studente di chimica è stata solo
a fare quali amici appoggiato di
rockabilly psychobilly sila alla ci si
diverte si scherza si fa tardi siamo
sulla strada del ritorno lo stradone di
campagna
una ragazza fa l'autostop ci fermiamo a
soccorrere la pulizia da quelli
cavalieri lei si accomoda dietro ciao
dove devi andare pochi in gioco dei
diamanti brown rumore di lamiere
accartocciate vecchiotti io me le
orecchie o come un inno di calabroni
qualcuno grida o il silenzio
state bene enrico sta bene luigi sta
bene la ragazza sta bene io sto bene
stiamo bene solo che io non sento le
gambe non le può poi aspettiamo
l'ambulanza l'unica cosa che riesco a
fare è cacciare le zanzare con il
braccio destro tutto il resto del mondo
mi portano la scuola la ferrara e da via
bologna per un'operazione due arresti
cardiaci
poi la rianimazione 20 giorni
una sera ho tanto male e così mi danno
sedativo che roba potente schermata
nola il mio fianco c'è un ragazzo è
cosciente e di un dato momento
la mattina dopo il dolore è abbastanza
passato il ragazzo box e più ce l'ha
fatta ragazzo io lo so come si chiamasse
non so perché era lì lo so nulla di lui
a lui è andato io però corallini servono
sette mesi in riabilitazione sono lunghi
sette mesi di lavoro di tesi gli
esercizi di lettino più statica che è un
affare che ti mette in verticale per che
soffrono di pressione bassa
basta poco un piccolo sforzo per spedire
e sono svenuto parecchie volte prima
delle dimissioni
i miei familiari veniamo convocati dal
primario
persona libera ma sicuramente competente
questo ci fa vedere un plastico mosca le
lettere ma col inermi e ci spiega che
praticamente avuto un bel colpo di
frusta la frusta dico adesso che ho
pensato di mesi prima tratto lavoro
tanto fesso terapia se sarebbe un
intervento 2 e si ritorna come modi o
quasi
no non è così tritano irreversibile se
trovate nasa o meglio si cambia in casa
le barriere architettoniche si lasciano
la città e si comincia una nuova vita
i primi anni sono come minimo fatti
tipici studia chi vuol dire un po
applicazione per la concetrazione un
esame il 2 l'anno non si va da nessuna
parte così qualche volta mi vengono anzi
spesso
amici altre volte e vengono a prendere
mi portano via fatto dei vigili che sono
divertito con loro sicuramente però non
si va da nessuna parte così passa
qualche anno e la danno la stessa cosa
dice
dipendesse si gioca sempre manuali qui
bisogna fare qualcosa succede qualcosa
ma le sfide succedono le cose belle e di
farla di dire devo fare qualcosa
sì ma cosa esso una delle prime cose
l'autonomia e quindi la patente che non
avevo se la padova fa la patente a fare
quelli che dovevano la macchina
perché devo guidare una macchina
opportunamente attrezzata la macchina
non ha stato sterzo una climatizzazione
e io faccio le guide a luglio quad
replicando quanto più soffro la versione
lassa e faticoso dietro ama e li
foraggia intenso che rate e cioccolatini
anche un po di export del farmaco quella
fetta che tutto regolare è prescritto
dal medico non sono tossico e quindi
patente e poi e poi devo pensare
all'università che faccio ma davanti
cambio
il tutto da qualche altra parte già
collaboro con delle persone
dell'ambientale devo finire
mamma che ne dici se torniamo a scuola
si sa diana e andiamo a creare ferrara a
seguire i corsi sapori dal lunedì al
venerdì segue i corsi laboratori faccio
gli esami ottimi ottimi voti e con la
dubai a motori ma sulla tesi
sperimentale discarica i campionamenti
quando d'estate prefettura naturalmente
andare col fresco e avanti e poi mi
viene la voglia di tenermi in forma
trovato il moto ma la padrona in
fermento ritrovo il ping pong l'avevo fa
per uno sparlare di grano in uno dei
tanti ricoveri che mi era piaciuto sì me
lo hanno detto che ero bravo ma io mi
sento inadeguato non colpevole tavolo
non era non era il massimo però ci
voglio ritrovarle
come faccio solo tetraplegico vuol dire
collegando il nuovo il busto e le
braccia così
di validità costringono praticamente
come faccio a tenere una racchetta
andiamo avanti
nietzsche duro molto duro
faccio fatica a mandare la pallina oltre
la rete faccio fatica a fare quei tre
colpi di solito non parliamo di un
allenamento di due web però vado avanti
prima una volta la settimana
poi due poi tre ma no vicino a casa a
vicenza dove c'è il mio coach giovanni
giovane è allenato per 10 a tante questa
moto è voluto mancare
volevo regalarli altre medaglie e magari
3 dalle 11 non ci sono riuscito però lui
mi ha dato tanto che hanno solo da
intervistare
mi alleno sempre di più la compagna
maria cristina de compagna la compagna
del momento con la quale una storia
importante tanto che almeno è tanto
facciamo anche discreti risultati che
venga convocato in nazionale nel 2009
per gli europei di 50 spiega come la
società o vado a sono riserva vuol dire
so però i singoli e fari mattina nella
gara di tim normale ma è già molto
già i singoli o un girone di ferro col
primo aperto è il numero uno al mondo
non si stavano il secondo molto forte
pare sia loro 56 al mondo tre a due per
me passo al girone e divento di diritto
in prima squadra anche nel team e ci
capita di giocarci la medaglia di bronzo
contro il peso il mio compagno molto
forte vincere i suoi due singoli
io parto singolo perdiamo il doppio
abbiamo l'ultima partita quella decisiva
ce l'ho io ho avuto una partita sofferta
lavoro l'ha fatta lui ma quella decisiva
tokamak 31 per me abbiamo vinto abbiamo
vinto il bronzo al mio più europeo
mi sembra di volare e questo perché
perché ho lavorato perché abbiamo
lavorato infatti io ho le mie stanze dei
giochi a casa mia al centro federale nei
luoghi dove ci alleniamo con la
nazionale mi allenavo box con gli spari
per quei compagni di squadra con i
tecnici della nazionale
giorno dopo giorno parecchie ore al
giorno e poi faccio i servizi da soli
poi un po di preparazione atletica
fino a quando io in queste stanze in sé
countdown tra tante orologi che se
segnano il tempo che fa
a una o più manifestazione dalla più
distante alla più vicina dalla più
importante alla più diciamo così alla
meno importante ma comunque provante e
fino a che arriva alla vigilia di una
partita
la sera vengono fuori che i gironi tra i
miei avversari
questo è forte queste forze sono tutti
forti a questi rivali ma solo fra
tacchino quale si va a riposare a volte
di più
all'attacco da meno la mattina si
alimenta le ceneri leggere ci si prepara
a meno un'ora e mezza dalla partita si
scalda propria compagna di squadra
almeno 40 minuti la polizia della
racchetta che deve essere tempo lita
meno 30 di inutile presentazione
all'arbitro si mostra la maglietta si
mostra la racchetta 6 regolare meno 15
minuti un po di relax magari si faccia
qualcosa si va al bagno musica meno
cinque minuti si entra nel campo di gara
si sono da un pubblico sorteggio dei
servizi meno due minuti piccolo
riscaldamento con l'avversario e poi
l'arbitro chiama pane ne stavo gato to
save versus the stars
qui e ora
tutto deve sparire il countdown gli
orologi i problemi e le sfide pensieri
le persone tutto deve sparire la
concentrazione deve essere massima sulla
pallina sul mio braccio sul braccio
dell'avversaria e sui suoi occhi la sua
tattica e la mia tattica e la
concentrazione deve essere massima e poi
si vince o sigarette
quando arriva la pallina io devo fare
delle scelte devo decidere se
schiacciare sia opportuno schiacciare se
piazzare la palla italiana non tenete ma
se dare alcun avversario la palla un po
più facile per evitare rischi rose
invece essere incisivo tante decisioni
in un sigo punto per tanti utili per
tante partite e discende ne ha fatte
tante
poi è silenzio si prenda e quasi lo
stesso non è vero
però di scelte ma fate tante volte
sbaglia è di marca volta andata bene e
non solo sul tavolo risentono anche
della vita io ho studiato mi sono
preparato a scegliere e non solo questo
perché ci sono state delle persone che
hanno scelto nei miei riguardi di
aiutare molto piano di tanto è molto più
che non ad aiutarmi e con mia mamma mia
sorella le persone che mi sono state
decine di amici erano scelto di aiutarmi
e ora ha fatto per il ruolo per dovere
non ho fatto perché mi amano perché mi
amavano e narrano ancora aveva fatto
proprio forse solo posto animati che
strano
[Musica]
aveva fatto per mattia amicizia tanti
più di quanto potesse immaginare
e se sono qui lo devo al mio lavoro al
mio impegno ma anche a loro sicuramente
per cui si ravvedano e le cause che la
vita cartina o piccoli descritti o
grande disguidi abbiate la
spregiudicatezza la sfrontatezza di fare
delle scelte
preparatevi fin d'ora fare delle scelte
preparatevi nonna a reagire contro
preparatevi ad agire però è il pro
dovete essere voi stessi amici ce ne
sono tanti in sala
segrate in tommaso cioè ci vediamo dopo
è questa il mio servizio come volete
scavi capitali ecco di faber
[Applauso]